we haven't even had the question yet
yeah i know it's gonna go like a
question you know we're not doing the
question we're cutting it out
but i wanna honestly we're cutting the
question there's no way i wanted to talk
about it you're not gonna get the record
i want you to have it i really don't
want you to have it i wanna i wanna talk
anyway let's have a round of applause
you talked about stardew valley was a
big hit on my podcast it was yeah
the clip of you just talking about this
little game that had over 300 thousand
views what the hell and the people on
the subreddit were going crazy they
loved it oh they were done i moved on i
did two characters with stardoo
i um i got um
10 million or 50 million dollars per
character which means that i had all the
wizard stuff like the towers and the
golden the golden clock where it takes
all the debris um it just gets to the
point where it's like i have so much
money
i don't even know i mean you can go to
this casino and buy this statue from
this guy which costs a million dollars
but i had 15 of those so i'd cost i
spent like 15 million dollars right oh
my god
yeah and then you're my kids are running
around and everything and then you just
get to the point where you go oh i'm 47.
in real life in real life in real life
and this is ridiculous
and then i started playing this other
game called far cry 5 10. i like that i
never played i loved it this is the best
one out of all is there ever a game you
play when you don't play after like 5 or
10 or 15 hours and you're like oh no i'm
47. like what games don't make
and i don't say that because i'm a gamer
too and part of the joy that's lost for
me is that i'm like i always have this
feeling of like i should be doing
something else even though i hate that i
want to be in the moment and just enjoy
the video games well you know i when
when jordan peele got that oscar
right i thought to myself
right this is a because he is he the one
that introduced me to video games really
yeah he is the one that introduced me to
i remember going to
the gamestop to get morrowind
right he's the one that goes you got to
get that game because he's like in the
rpg is it cool bethesda so
and then he stopped playing stop smoking
pot and in that now he is now he's
a you know academy award winner right
i'm
i mean even if i didn't play video games
i would never be able to do what he does
because
right but my point is is that i could
have achieved more
but the pleasure that i get from it i
mean outrageous
outweighs an oscar throw that off
no i before
when i was working a desk job a day job
at nine to five yeah i would come home
and play video games and it was like
that was my joy you know and i i feel
like that joy's gone i don't know if
it's because i'm depressed i don't know
if it's because i've
maybe it's because i'm depressed i don't
know
but i feel like there's always a there's
always like a sensor in me that's like
you should be doing something else yeah
and you know what that's a normal
healthy thing i just don't have that i
refuse to get it
you know there's a balance i'm gonna
play tonight i'll give a [ __ ] what are
you gonna play tonight i started over
with i finished far cry 5 and i started
over with
and it's a grinding game too did you
play god of war
i hate slashers he doesn't do he doesn't
do playstation i don't know i don't do
playstation and i also don't i don't
like slash from hackem stuff
you know i mean i like um it's very rpg
though too i know it is okay that's
great
but i like
i like far cry because um i should play
far cry i like sneaking yeah
i like taking my binoculars and scoping
out a compound open world and finding
out where everyone is right i like
figure out how to get into the compound
without anyone seeing me right i like
throwing rocks
you can throw a watch stealth boy yeah
when you throw a rock the k the
characters go who
what's your favorite game of all time
he's trying to end the show yeah my
favorite game of all yeah yeah
my favorite yeah my favorite game of all
time i'm not the host
i was wondering if you were a fallout
guy which one though
i really enjoyed the last one
four yeah i never played four because
everybody says oh it's just like three
and i know it's nice
it's not even because i love
i love
fallout fallout and i skipped the whole
[ __ ] thing because everybody
dissuaded me no fallout 4 is the
masterpiece because what about new vegas
it's way better because okay i'm gonna
play it then i'll tell you why new vegas
is better than new vegas because new
vegas there was no house right oh you
like the house aspect i like building a
house from ground up
huh you could be you can
but you know i came home and i um needed
to catch up
on the destiny
because everyone did i played the whole
time i was gone
and now i'm behind
and i played yesterday but i got in
trouble
why did he get in trouble kalyala
um let's see he comes through the door
drops his suitcase gets a haagen-dazs
yeah ice cream before he doesn't finish
it makes it melt on the floor
[Laughter]
yeah in a span of three minutes turns
our home into an absolute just like
crime scene yeah that watches the dog
you know piss in front of him on the
floor
and then proceeds to scream for 10 hours
straight at the tv i mean tell me
what what type of person i would have to
be
to not at least be
to be even you know annoyed
and
i didn't
that i was trying to communicate to him
and then he goes oh hey i'm going to
dinner with eric at 7 30. mind you i've
been sick all weekend didn't offer me no
food okay
no meds then offer me a kiss or a hug
shut the [ __ ] up with your own man oh
you didn't kiss you look at me right now
wait wait wait stop right now right now
no it's not right here babe i'm sorry i
apologize but i'm gonna look at me right
now if you ever give me a [ __ ] o like
that again my friend all right you you
have another thing coming
which is i don't know
oh god it's a mystery it's a mystery
it's a mystery one all right so i want
you to [ __ ] apologize gilbert i'm
sorry that i said oh when you didn't
kiss your girlfriend when you got home
you're welcome
and i forgive you oh go ahead baby
um
i mean it's the same argument we always
have i have a pretty high threshold for
video
she's the best girlfriend in the world i
don't tell him when to stop i don't give
him like a treat baby baby but yesterday
i was sick and i just needed a little
bit of like hi kala i know you exist and
you're sick and you're dying on a bed i
needed just just an ounce of it
that's it and i was trying to
communicate that to him and all he said
to me was i'm after playing 10 hours he
says i don't want to talk about it i'm
too tired i need a nap
and then he goes and
doesn't talk to me okay and then yeah
yeah and um and then um
he wakes up he goes to dinner and then
at dinner he realizes what he had done
number one okay i want you to apologize
what for what
i want you to apologize right now kalila
for what just to do it just
he always makes me do this yeah yeah
just to do it you say i am so sorry you
know what bobby i really am sorry that
you have just zero capacity
i heard sorry and that's all i need to
do
and number two walk into a town
it's living and breathing i mean i watch
graphics pretty i mean it's not even
just good it's like i walked to
a it was a store you know like a general
store
and there was like five guys just one
guy leaning against a wall
some guy sitting on a thing you know
and it just it looked so real
the way he opens the door it's not like
he just opens it like he would open the
door yeah like it's everything is so
real how are the weapons and the mods
and steve
okay
i want to [ __ ] get to it man sorry
sorry sir
jesus okay
another good thing about the game is is
that
the weather system oh yeah
the wind
the way the trees sweat it you could
just feel it you know
it's it's just gorgeous and it's one of
those things where you if you're a gamer
you just have to play it
it's just they spent what five years on
it probably more than that honestly yeah
i mean it you can it's on the screen
everything about it the detail i mean
it you i don't know how anything works
the little symbols on the bottom they
don't really teach you they don't teach
you
you have to figure it out in real life
like real life
i mean there's one guy there was one
poor guy i murdered on by a river with a
bow and arrow with the bone area oh it's
an open world like that yeah and i
accidentally did it he was like hey
buddy
come here i want to show you something
and you should kill them and i had my
bow and arrow and
if you press left trigger
if you don't have a thing you can start
a dialogue but i had a weapon so i
pressed left trigger
and i go hey like this right and he goes
hey buddy and he shot me right and then
i i put my bowl arrow right through his
neck he dies and all of a sudden little
symbol says that you know i mean that
because
i guess karma yeah yeah that's in there
yeah that's in there yeah it's like it's
like westworld you're the bad guy or the
good guy yeah yeah it really is there
are animals you can hunt oh my god
it's not only that the way they die
the animals it's realistic
so it takes forever they
you know i mean they stumble for a while
right they fall and they're still
breathing you put them out of their
misery you can put them on their misery
yeah and then
skinning them takes about 10 minutes
it's you you have to open up the clock
it's pretty good it's almost too easy
it's almost too realist but it is a
masterpiece you haven't download you'll
never play it right well the reason
being is i played the the crap out of
the first one i i was telling you i was
playing the games within the games like
poker and then there's darts yeah yeah
and i i just know i know i know me i
know the darts yeah dude
all of it i know me as i will just
lose myself in that way all right so but
you so what your point of view though is
is that
you don't want to play red dead
redemption because you don't want to
play video games for that long but last
night what time did you play till
me and griffin played till like
three four in the morning yeah yeah what
are you guys what time did you start we
did it we did like this destiny yeah wow
i could wean off destiny that's the
reason no you can't you can't every time
i come to your house you're playing no
no i could quit i could no you're in
denial no i could quit it the reason why
you won't play red dead redemption is
not because of the fact that you don't
want to be playing video games is
because you don't want you want you
don't want to stop playing destiny
god damn it
um star dude valley it surprises me
oh that game is evil i actually started
playing myself you did too yeah i've
been playing soccer 16 hours non-stop
every day oh wow
if you guys don't know about this game
it's called stardew valley it's a farm
simulation game you get an xbox
playstation has it mostly the computer
people play it on the computer
and it is
if you like simulation games
and you like rpg elements oh my god it's
the greatest thing i've ever played i
really believe that it's the best game
ever made
i have more fun playing this game not
than foul out because yeah
that's the ultimate rpg it's more
satisfying
because it's fallout things uh
things do grow but it's like
in a different kind of way
here it's like there's some strategy
involved
there's um a lot of creativity in terms
of layout
but there's all these you really like
just
charming cute things that happen music
is cute yeah it's just a cute really
good game
you know i i finally made it to calico
desert how's it different from like the
sims
well the sims from what i recall i
haven't played it in years but it's like
you're in a neighborhood you're
basically in your own house no rpg
elements there's no rpg elements no
adventure just simulation yeah there's
things that happen in stardew valley
that you go oh my god you thought of
that
you know like you you can think this guy
you you see his art piece and you see oh
this guy thought it through
oh that's [ __ ] cute you got to own a
cat
yeah not a cat you have cows a chicken
who's your girlfriend what's your name i
don't have a girlfriend yet nobody don't
i thought you said penny was yours i've
been giving penny diamonds but oh you
get to like create relationships oh you
know you to get married and have kids
yeah
yeah i've been courting emily you
haven't gotten married yet oh he's met
emily i think no because i'm too busy
making money and upgrading my house and
doing the real [ __ ] yeah some process
[ __ ] what kind of sword do you have i
have the galaxy sword the number one
sword i've just got that bug one that
you get for free yeah i'm still i'm in
year two
i'm into your year two i had the galaxy
sword
anyway george really here right sorry
i'm about to get married emily you know
i gave her a bouquet i actually got a
dance at the spring festival
that was so exciting because the first
year i like got denied for the dance at
the spring festival then i figured out
how to do it you know the second at the
spring festival you know what i did
never even went
[ __ ] it making money he was really upset
because there was like a community
function and then you had to contribute
to making
soup
and he didn't have any ingredients so he
put tree bark
so you're done with festivals and so his
community or his festival the people
like turn against you right because
they're like why did he put tree bark in
our soup well he almost killed the
governor
yeah i know but there's this thing what
i like about the game is is that when
you're in the mines every once in a
while this thing called the strange bun
you'll drop you can eat it it's got you
know it helps with their health and
whatnot but there's this thing in this
game if you take the strange bun
and you go into vincent's room there's a
kid named vincent and you put the
strange bun inside his green cabinet you
get a reward
and what you get is the funniest thing
i've ever seen what is it
i don't know what it is
i mean i have it why is it so funny it's
basically just a green glob
a green glove statue
that's like you put in your house
it's pretty high
and it's just a melting green looks like
a man
right but it's just solid green and it's
the middle of my bedroom i love it but
there's all these cute little weird
things in there that you're like oh
that's [ __ ] cool
you know i did something happened to me
today where
gunther the museum guy
came to my house and he said um
well you know now you know
the city another city
is giving us a reward
you did such a great job because it's
all filled almost
and he gave me a rusty key i don't know
where it goes but oh it's a key to the
city that's like a big deal
right i know it's a rusty key for to
open something
that's a whole adventure yeah so my
point is is that if you like but it's
also the graphics are like zelda it's 80
zelda
the graphics are like 80s cute
you know pixelate almost pixel
oh it sucks you in because you always
i'll just play one day
and then it's like
oh but tomorrow's the next thing
happening tomorrow is gonna be
somebody's birthday that i have to give
them like a gift so that like i get to
be double friends with yeah yeah yeah
and then like oh the the next festival's
coming oh and then i hope it rains so
that i can get like
go fishing for a walleye so it sucks
even like very easily yeah cause there's
always little things that you can like
complete and then it opens more of the
world yeah yeah and also there's
millions of things to do
so you have like 15 things in your head
that you have to do i got to get this
seed fall is almost here i gotta prepare
for that
you put you know my layout of my land
yeah
so there's just a million things i gotta
go to my i need silver
you know
i need it i'm almost out of copper man
i'm always fighting to get copper i have
enough battery packs now
because you can now make you could also
make things crafting which is what you
like i love crafting yeah so
it's if you if you like games guys
[ __ ] get it
you know
but i'm glad i'm back though it'll suck
you in yeah it'll suck in but
for a second though okay just for a
second though is you're right
i
i mine
i have mind before
yeah okay
but i only mine
when the pain gets great enough
when you have to when i'm suffering
so much
what you know i'll give you an example
i have one new joke
that i wrote in the last month right
yeah but the reason why i did that joke
was because when i was driving in the
store i was gonna jump off a cliff
like i was like on the i was like i'm
gonna kill my and i'm like you if you
don't in my head
if you don't try that joke
you mean it's it
you're gonna relapse
so i went up on stage with that mindset
and i said it and it did well and now
it's a part of my repertoire but i have
to get there
can you go to that place i can't
how did you do it before and here's the
pro i'll tell you it it has to do with
oh it's because i'm crazy
it has to do with
video games
and
because at that time i was in between
video games
just hear me out
i was it was i was done with far cry 5.
yeah i've done the i've done the mars
i've done all that right
and i had nothing
and so did you notice that i was
watching a lot of star trek next
generation yes
right and watching a lot of videos and
movies that i do that
and also i i did that with um
handmade stills as well
i i go into that when
i have no video game to play
but then no man's sky came
and it's consumed me
right
so um
so to get to that place you have to have
no options of video games yes
yeah it's um dave we talked to dave cho
yesterday and he was like dude most
addicts don't have just one form of
addiction it comes in
they usually have a dozen addictions
and i'm going to tell you why
no man's sky
right
is an addiction and why
i like it and why i escaped through it
is because it's a game where you have 50
things you have to do and so you're
you're focused on i gotta get copper i
gotta get to make this because i have to
build this
to get this ship to make this money and
to get this freighter and i have so much
to do
that it just it takes me out of my own
self
and my problems
and
and if i'm not doing that
then i start like feeling the pain
and then when i feel the pain
i go to star trek next generation
handmaid's tale right but
but it's in those moments of
is when i start writing and this and
that but like video games really affects
it you know what i mean
you're a gamer right yeah what do you
play i mean i play fortnite right now
but i used to play counter strike oh wow
are you the only person in the world who
isn't playing fortnite do you want do
you want to scream you want me to scream
every night oh that's no he will because
i suck at fortnite right now yeah the
building part and then also the fact
that you have to
you have to aim correctly on sniping
where you have to like
you have to time it where it's like all
right this person might be moving to
this place and i need to aim a little
bit above because it's not like if
they're getting in your crosshairs
you're you're getting that snipe yeah
you got to make sure like if how far
away you are and everything well it's
like destiny the reason why i stopped
playing destiny was because of pvp
and because every time i die scream
where i get angry i throw controllers oh
me too you know i mean or if my
teammates my fire team isn't doing what
i want them to do
you know like there's fights like what
are you doing that's not done why are
you behind that wall we're over here
shooting i told you to be here
she's like i don't know i just thought
that i could do a side thing
and sneak around
i know like stick around and surprise
them like you're not even that good so
you would have died anyway
you know i mean it's that kind of thing
so it's always a liability yeah you're
gonna have too many liabilities there
but no do when you here's another thing
i don't like about fortnite is when you
die
they take your [ __ ]
oh you mean do they take the stuff that
you picked up in the game yeah yeah
that's i mean it's a match you don't get
it every time
but imagine this imagine if you died in
real life and then people started taking
and they took your [ __ ] dj spinning
the spinning things that you do yeah i
guess he walks around
i never did anything i never thought
about it like that but yeah yeah it's
not good that's yours yeah that is that
was when they take mine they don't take
mine okay
so what else do you so you only play
like pvp stuff yeah you're not a fallout
you don't like bethesda stuff like rpgs
single players no not really
i used to on dreamcast i forgot the game
that i used to play yeah way back it was
dream sketch
yeah
no was this one where was like this like
you could play as four characters and
they had these weird arms that you could
like throw elemental things oh yeah i
don't remember that i don't remember was
that a role-playing game yeah
well but you know what that and dude i
broke so many that's why i don't play
role-playing games because i broke so
many controllers because when you're
sitting there and you can't like you
can't hurt them you have to like wait
your turn for them no so what you're
saying okay those are
turn-based role-playing games okay my
bad
well final fantasy and that that is
probably a tournament
you you attack then you have to wait for
everyone to attack and it's your turn
again yeah but the rpgs that i play now
like the ones that bethesda do are like
real-time rpgs
right what is that so basically it's
open world okay you when you shoot a gun
like fortnight you shoot somebody yeah
like obviously not a a real person by
character in the game right
and a game like um fallout for instance
you can build a home
[Music]
you know like you can use
build a beautiful home
with defenses
you can have a dog you can go out you
don't have to
kill things you can just pick things up
like i need to go get
wood
and also
this you know like detergent yeah but
other and other people are in this world
trying to shoot you no no it's just no
it's open no it's it's a single player
and then you go in and you fight mutants
you fight other people so you just want
a home to come home too no that's not
what it is i like gta
it's kind of in many ways a gta but gta
you can't okay because i love gta it's
like gta but you can't desi like rp the
bethesda game i'm talking about yeah is
you can design wear whatever you want to
wear design the facial structure
the ethnicity of your person
height all that stuff yeah okay and then
also you can wear clothing that you want
to wear yeah although gt has that you
can go to a clothing store but the
options are limited yeah in um
the rpgs now especially the bethesda
ones which i'm talking about elder
scrolls skyrim or the fallout series
yeah and then you can um the maps are
gigantic
and it's just a lot of fun man
i mean i was going to get fallout for
xbox and then i never did it because i
just i watched the the trailer and i
just didn't do it but i'll do it for you
no you don't have to do it for me i will
but if you're saying it's
good mean because i didn't know anyone
that played fallout
oh my god
oh my god it's like
i might not go to the movie now because
i'm having like an internal thing just
add me build my salad all right the
thing is is that
but how about this i'll do the new
fallout 76 is coming out in november
and
it is a pvp oh multiplayer multiplayer
in it everyone's doing battle royale
that's the new thing it's the new thing
right so kayla's doing one problem it's
got it you can do it's it's got all this
elements of fallout where you single
player you can build a house you can go
out there's story lines missions and
stuff that you can do on your own yeah
but then you can also do things with
other people but what i would do if i
was awesome what i would do if i were
you you have an xbox one i have both ps4
what do you that dj what do you play on
no no they sent it to me xbox one you
get free [ __ ] yeah as a dj
he's he's famous that's why i have
popular because i get so much free [ __ ]
i don't have to pay for it
what are you i didn't buy these shoes do
this for me get fallout 4
get fallout 4. okay i didn't buy this
shirt either
you get free [ __ ] i bought the hat
though yeah
i bought this made worn wait wait wait
wait you play on xbox
yeah but i want you to get fallout 4
right okay i want you to
i want you to play it i will no i'm
being real i will start a character
legit will play it
um and
see can we do some missions together no
we can't do it in fallout 4 because they
don't have that yet in november but
that's why i want to see i want you to
play football so i can get used to it
you can get used to it if you don't even
like the world then [ __ ] it when anyone
do it i want to waste my time okay
because when i play fallout 76 you're
playing listening right now listen to me
right now i'm going to be full in it
okay i'm so flexible but she did
introduce sturdy valley to ilani and the
lonnie introduced it that's true what a
great concept i'm not sure i'm not
downing i'm not i i'm bummed that you're
dating you're not dating her anymore
she introduced me to a [ __ ] farming
world man i
started valley i i hated on it but then
she like you just gotta try it i did and
i loved it i played are you kidding me i
i saw how much long i played on it i
played for 24 days straight 24 hour
circle cycle that's what it says on the
machine damn
the game is dangerous yeah so i played
for i don't know how many that hours
that is
but i imagine 24 hours a day 24 days and
you know
that's insane
well i you don't even they cause that
they calculate
fallout and and all those other games i
hate that they track that stuff oh they
tracked me on
i think elder scrolls oblivion that's
log
i played
for maybe like 48 days
straight
straight
50 days like no i mean i would sleep but
it would calculate you know i mean the
hours i played and that's what it was
oh destiny
oh my god it was like we me and eric
we the number was so high
that we almost wanted to kill ourselves
we said we could have wrote three
scripts in that time
but the pleasure of playing
out beats any oscar you could have right
it really does
it really does
my brother and i were playing far cry
today
and um we were climbing this cliff
together you know it was one of those
proper statuses that you had to climb a
bunch of [ __ ] yeah and you have to swing
on these ropes and you'll climb it yeah
right one yeah and i'd make it and i see
my brother because i don't know what to
do i don't know what to do right and you
see his character just fall
out right a thousand feet and just get
cr die
and then i'm laughing you're right
and my brother's going i'm dead i'm dead
i go you don't even know how to do that
it's those moments in video games is so
fun and fallout 76 is gonna be that it's
gonna ruin me when does it come out in
october well we have a new house by then
november yes for sure okay great then
i'm fine i will bend i mean but that
thing is gonna be six people i'll be
[ __ ] all better
um
where the dude wakes up in her dorm room
and she's like in a different she's all
like contorted and stuff is like emily
rose or something like that yeah that
one yeah oh yeah the girl from dexter
yeah we know
you know what you're talking about yeah
i'm bent baby um